you ever sent The Accidental nudie to
the family no have you I know I read a
story on Reddit one girl said I sent a
nude of me to my mom
and we just agreed to delete it and
never talk about it again someone else
said I sent a nude of me to the family
group chat no no
oh my God can we pull can we find that
thread you might just send that [__] in
your dad's like just like your mom yeah
thank you
what that's disgusting I've seen it
before that is horrible I seen her when
she was young
too dark a little bit
sorry yeah I've never I've never done
that I've never done the nudity to the
fam yeah I'm sure they'd roast me though
dad's like I didn't pass down everything
did I yeah you could not get that for me
the whole family's like whose dick is
that
all the male members start sending
pictures of their dick it's not mine
this [__] is hung
he definitely did not get that hell
Helen do you have an affair yeah
no LOL
I'm perfectly satisfied Cody that's
really weird
your whole family becomes very concerned
yeah digging up pictures of your
grandparents and [__] yeah yeah whose
dick is that taking pictures of great
grandparents oh this is this is Leroy
right here
I sent news to my family group God damn
no okay zoom in you can't zoom in on her
nudes dude come on
the cocky
last night my girlfriend's my
girlfriends
asked me to send wait what he has
multiple girlfriends is that what what
the hell asked me to send might be a she
and it's like my girlfriend's oh oh okay
yeah my girlfriend's okay last night my
girlfriends asked me to send why KW and
what is that you know what okay you know
what and because that's a 15 year old
and because I was tired and couldn't
think straight I accidentally sent it to
my family group chat what should I do
now my mom messaged me privately and
said remove that right now
[Music]
remove this message oh here we go here
we go scroll up Scroll up I'm 19 male 12
people in the chat with immediate family
and a few cousins yo this dude is
freaking out okay reset now we gotta
read it in his voice yeah okay
so last night my girlfriends asked me to
send you know what and because I was
tired and couldn't think straight I
accidentally sent a picture of my [__]
to the whole family group chat
what should I do now
I have messages a group chat I am so
sorry that was meant to be sent to my
doctor for medical reasons I have
deleted the pic
I mean that's a honestly kind of a good
excuse
like what else is there to say there's
nothing else you could say
all right as hell yeah
yeah
just trying to get some confirmation by
my doctor that my that my swag is on
600.
my erection is fully powered okay son
why you got a snapback in that photo
watch your head backwards why is it from
this angle why is it from the bottom why
are you wearing puka shells I told you
throw those out
we told you no puka shells inside where
did you get those
why is it from the bottom and you're
looking off yeah why are you looking out
from behind it
like peeking off from behind your penis
like a cartoon character this [__] is
crazy
[Laughter]
why is there come all over a picture of
someone's face
that's a tribute and I need you to not
ask questions
that's a tribute for my doctor
oh my god dude you're going in for some
[__] semen sample they're like
okay uh if you wouldn't mind just uh
doing a little tribute into this cup and
I'll uh I'll come back in a few minutes
this is a plastic go with a picture of
the doctor on the underside
oh for sure I'm gonna tribute okay
tribute me
tribute
foreign
fourth update no one has replied four
updates no one has replied and it's
making me more and more worse
it's making me more and more hard yeah
the thing is why would you what would
you want them to say oh just LOL yeah
cousin law Fifth and most likely last
update my stepsister and Aunt left the
groups at my step sis
she's like
oh my God
my suspicions are confirmed
my stepbrother
has a nice wiener
yeah my sister my stepsister added me on
Snap right after this
[Laughter]
um why did uh seventh update my
stepsister said we can keep it in the
family
eighth update the eighth update my it
turns out my stepsister is stuck in the
washer
God damn man
final update
oh my my stepsister and aunt got added
back
that's kind of funny
someone was like no no you we if we got
to suffer through this you gotta suffer
yeah come on come on get back in there
get back in here they had arranged a
family event where we would go out for
food and my other aunt was the one who
arranged it so she said I have booked
the restaurant
I don't think she saw the picture as far
as I know only six people have saw it
that's hilarious not to know the like
tension and awkwardness that's going on
in the group chat and just pop in and be
like hey I booked the reservation guys
broke up for 5 p.m right are we good
also advertisers have to be pre-ordered
so what are we into mozzarella sticks
pepperoni blasters or Salad yeah and I
need to know before 4 45 yeah or just
things that are phallic yeah it's either
just
their egg rolls are good but they're too
big yeah
it's a lot it's a mouthful if you know
what I mean
the mozzarella sticks are thinner they
go down easier I love the ranch that
they serve with those um
I love the feeling of biting into a
mozzarella they're moth sticks and all
the goo comes out
but gooey cheese
um
I'm dyslexic I don't know why I read
that as I'm 19 I'm a 19 male prepper
just meal prepper no like a doomsday I'm
a 19 male prepper
what a sick way to classify yourself
yeah I'm a prepper final update dinner
was really awkward I kept pretending I
needed to go to the restroom when in
reality I was just trying to get a break
from how uncomfortable I felt this is
the final update Jesus man why is the
phrase it's like that this is the final
update
this is my final Reddit post top comment
this was my step brother yeah
um we've changed his identity so we can
get married
what's the top comment on this
bro I thought it said send it like send
the nude like just show us
apologize this guy Master advice giver
apologize and try to laugh it off thanks
dude thanks man appreciate it
just laugh it off bro oh sorry that was
my [__]
just
[Laughter]
hello crying emojis just trying to push
it up
[Music]
you're reacting to it like yeah
isn't this so funny cut everyone off and
move to a random country and start a new
life yeah yeah dude yeah if the doctor
thing doesn't work that's what you have
to do oh man yeah like it was this
before you could unsend messages can't
you unsend them now you can can you
delete the pic from the chat otherwise
just roll with whatever happens my aunt
was looking at some photos and she's
super nosy and scrolled over one too
many and saw a pic of me and some undies
Sans bra oh she said as I swiftly remove
my phone from her hand
hmm I think you gotta own it I think you
just gotta send thoughts question mark
yeah uh nice nice you know yeah
don't make it sexual just just be like
hey honest thoughts is this good what
does the family prove I'm about to send
this to someone yeah yeah like what do
you guys think I I appreciate your
opinion you know
most you know most people engage in
degenerate behavior and people would say
What's it what would your family think
about this and so I want to be honest I
kind of want to take a different line of
reasoning here and get my family's
thoughts first yes exactly
so honest thoughts on my [__]
dad is it anything like yours
last time I saw it I was like five I
used to [__] hit it I thought it was
funny but
I don't know that period of being a
young like a young boy and you realize
you could hit your dad in the nuts is so
funny I've never hit my dad in The Nut
oh dude I punched my dad in the nuts and
he was he like buckled over and I
thought it was so funny and there was
this period where I just try to Sock him
in the nuts
and my nephew had the same thing
he he hit my brother along the nuts and
he and he was like ah [__] it
and he immediately understood what was
going on he thought it was hilarious
yeah and he just was going through a
period where he would just [__] you
could just sacked at him
that's that's funny yeah yes that's
really good yeah I see why my parents
neglected me at times